-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all
doing well tonight.
And now, we're going to
get to the news.
President Biden hosted
the first movie screening
of his presidency tonight
at the White House.
And according to Jill, his last.
"Who's that again?
Why is she mad at him?
Did that guy just die?"
[ Laughter ]
Tesla CEO Elon Musk tweeted
yesterday that former president
Donald Trump's platform Truth
Social has a terrible name.
Um, okay, "Elon Musk."
[ Laughter ]
Dr. Anthony Fauci said this week
that the country is now
out of the pandemic phase of
the coronavirus and firmly in
the "remembering how to
talk to people" phase.
"Hello, coworker!
How was your weekend?
Plus, what's a sad memory
from your childhood?"
[ Laughter ]
In newly released excerpts from
a deposition taken last year,
former president Trump said that
he was worried
that protesters might throw
fruits and vegetables at him.
This is just more proof that
Trump only thinks in cartoons.
"They could throw tomatoes,
or worse, someone could drop
an anvil on my head,
and then cracks would appear
on my face and body, and I might
crumple into a pile of dust
with just two eyeballs
sitting on top.
And then, folks, the eyeballs,
the eyeballs would blink twice."
[ Laughter ]
Goonk, goonk.
According to the latest numbers,
$7 billion of military equipment
was left in Afghanistan
last year
after the U.S. withdrew
from the country.
It's the oldest trick
in the book --
leave something behind
after the breakup
to give you an excuse
to go back.
"Yeah, hey, did I leave
some Humvees over there?"
[ Laughter ]
According to a new poll, nearly
80% of Americans are concerned
about misinformation influencing
the outcome of November's
midterm elections, and about 35%
are counting on it.
[ Laughter ]
Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer
and House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
today announced a new plan
to lower gas prices.
It's essentially a new gas pump
where every third gallon
is just Arizona iced tea.
[ Laughter ]
Russian President Vladimir Putin
said yesterday that
if any country interferes with
his attack on Ukraine,
"they must know our response to
counterstrikes will be
lightning fast,
unless, of course,
there's a little bit of mud."
[ Laughter ]
A family in Illinois recently
found a bag of McDonald's
French fries while renovating
their home that may
have been in the wall
for more than 60 years.
Man! It is hard to believe that
60 years ago,
those fries were hot
for three minutes.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the NFL Draft kicks
off tonight in Las Vegas,
where 31 lucky players
will avoid the Jets.
And that, you guys,
was a monologue.